today's guest has a new special coming
up on Netflix she is she's multi-faceted
and she's a wonderful storyteller
she's very entertaining and and I'm
happy that she's here with me today the
wonderful fortune themed stir
[Music]
amanda bynes got a face tactic we bring
that up nash fortune thanks for coming
in hey Theo thanks for having me yeah
yeah man that's cool nice to see you
yeah it's really sweet of you to come by
appreciate it um yeah wait can you bring
it up Nick sorry I just want to see this
I just saw this on the news
Oh Amanda bond got that face hitter
right there hey it's not even a good
heart is that a heart it looks like it's
like a so I got drunk and yeah try to
make a heart but it's like kind of a
lopsided oh it's like a tattoo of Buddy
years would give you like in Syracuse or
something at a party you know or like
there's like a Flint Michigan basic
white person to kind of tattoo I think
she doesn't like anything like she used
to look she um it's so common now with
face tattoos it's almost like you know I
have this idea sometimes that in the
future or the lair of like this layer of
skin will be will wear like an actual
protective layer of skin in the future
because maybe the sun will just be
murdering all of us oh that's a good
reason I think my thoughts were just
that it'll become like an old idea like
oh my god you wore your natural skin
idiot you know like we'll eventually
have like a newer layer because it also
seemed like people are on the like
people are just like faced adding and
just totally like the old layer it's
like getting all up here it's like
people are just at the end of the road
with the old layer yeah the dry skin
yeah we're gonna be one of the last
people to like have one our natural skin
really just like yeah yeah and I think
that was blow it on almost like with um
like a pressure wash it on or like uh
maybe a tanning bed if you ever go to
like one of the stand-up once I have it
up
once yeah and it's not great
well I would uh in my hometown no I
bought like I definitely been so you had
no tanning bed shame here yeah no
tanning bed shame but I this is
obviously not a body that tans easily
really he's about it a burn oh yeah and
and this body has not seen the light of
day ever as much as you know I'd love to
rock it to peace oh yeah I'd see in the
two feet so I'm in college I bought like
a package of four sessions for eating
better whenever I went to one and I was
like all right is not bad and the second
time I went um I got undressed which you
know is a feet just getting undressed
takes a lot of time and thank you wear a
belt or no yeah our belt yeah and I got
into the tanning bed and they hadn't
turned it on and I was like and I'm like
hello no one's light listen because it's
like part of it's a tanning bed and
other parts is so long tanning bed yeah
used to work at a place called frozen
options and we had awesome bootleg
tanning that people got pinkeye from the
bed no really
but anyway yeah like no one's turned it
and on and I'm just like sitting there
it's getting cold and I got put my
clothes back on there's another good ten
minutes yeah it's misery and I like
people my head back hello like no one's
doing things so I just I had seen her
turn it on before so I just made I just
turned it on and you put you know the
ten minutes where I mean that's a good
amount so I turn it on and I get
entertainment I do my thing I get out
and they're all like looking at me like
they had like looked in the I don't know
a video or something like I had tried to
get more time oh like you try to sneak a
minute I think a minute I'm all like no
I did the appropriate amount of time I
paid for it but I could never go back
after that because they were giving me
such a stink out like I had stolen candy
or something damn Oh
[ __ ] in here stealing I was like my
body can't even take extra hot minute
I'm telling you I just y'all weren't
doing your job
[Applause]
that was my I got uh I got a tanning bed
shame did you feel them did you feel the
tan after was it real did you get too
much did you get yeah I mean I was like
red yeah I mean I was I mean my guys tan
is my body pigmentation will allow your
body only goes so tan yeah and then it
just turns to freckles yeah so for me
it's like straight to cancer go straight
cancer and if we ever go out to like a
beach or something I'm that [ __ ] with
like a towel all over my body where you
like this much of my face cuz I just I'm
like no one expects me to be tan you're
begging kids to bury you in the sand
you're like alright I got three
umbrellas cover me it's not sexy yeah I
think I used to love tanning my mom used
to open the windows in our apartment by
the she would move the dinner table over
and open the windows and put a lawn
chair right there oh yeah
it's you have a little bit of beer and
get catch some Sun right there yeah but
let me say that one more time Nick do
you mind mother um I guess she got it
huh
is it permanent I mean it looks like
some of my nephew is it off your honor
yeah it looked like a large saw I think
it's a heart you remember when she our
remember she was a childhood star and
then she really I guess she's I don't
she struggled from addiction or admit
she had mental health issues but she
went might have been in calm calm but I
don't remember but I mean she was known
when she was growing up has been very a
girl next door you know she was in all
those movies where she played the cutesy
yeah you know not yes girl
and then
yeah yeah she windy she was like
tweeting about one and rate murder black
crime in America okay I don't think that
we need and I think is the guy's gonna
murder the [ __ ] but maybe like he got
one that was he in tickly mi you know
Gila romantic with it but I think that
was the cry for help where everyone's
like oh no she's in trouble yeah things
are going well thanks oh then she threw
a bong out of a window to I think I
remember really oh there's the Drake
right didn't he
what not the correct term murder my
vagina sorry I made it crass er sorry
lady mercy she was a lady about it and
she said murder my vagina
yeah that's right gangster actually well
I think I'd read a story about her like
a year ago where she had gotten she's
gone to get some help
I don't know from the mental stuff for
any sort of addiction I'm not sure what
it was and she was taking classes at the
Fashion Institute a while in downtown so
she was trying to get it you know do
something new yeah pull it together and
man she felt like she didn't want to be
a celebrity oh yes she graduated college
she didn't get him
yeah just in June fit him you wanted to
fit him fit him
you know what's interesting um there's a
when I was I was working on a dog show
one time or a pet shower song this years
ago and uh on the show it was Yahoo's
hosting was about pets or something
something about Animalia you know yeah
and so we went to a dog place where they
had where rich people had their dogs go
for the day if they were gonna be out of
town yeah and it's nice in there they
got astroturf and they got [ __ ]
magical you know they got food from like
exotic you know like the dogs revving
turkey four chefs make yes crazy like
he's here for the pot and like stirring
CBD oil
the guy's got a white glove yeah one dog
was getting uh one duck was getting a
diamond put on one of his incisors in
his mouth I get was [ __ ] and I was
Little John's dog actually dude they
said that this is true they said that
Little John's dog gave him there for a
month and that uh and he had gotten the
top-of-the-line stuff for it so all the
dogs had to play in one area and then
Little John's dog had his own [ __ ]
like a little but amanda bynes dog had
been there for two months
oh and it was a like a hot it would look
like a slipper that was alive you know
one of those kind of dogs yeah big
slipper a big furry sir yes for you to
know where the eyes were you know the
ass was yeah you'd like to give it a
treat and it suddenly put the Treat in
it but you know you were like where's
the face on this thing oh my gosh and
but it loved me dude it was following me
around like a [ __ ] hottie walk you
know man and um and they're like hey
we'll give it to you 4,000 bucks you
know it's been here for so long that we
you know we can't really board it
anymore we're gonna have to give it up
flex is pricy that's at the time it was
real pricey for me yeah you know now I
might go 800 on the [ __ ] Bichon all
right but that dog didn't sound like
$1,000 dog but it loved me though yep it
was almost like the parent I never had
like in the distance to it every time I
turned around it was like about 30 feet
away [ __ ] just like kind of little
yeah kind of indirectly coming out of
the fur it could have been a poem but
yeah so uh and I and I and I and I said
no and I wish how to say yes I'm sure
they don't really like me up yeah you
have a dog now I don't I've never had a
dog yeah that was the closest I ever
came was havin Amanda bonds dog and so
uh I wonder what
that dog I don't know see if there's any
information about that we make a nick
work today can you can you get its
tracking number a man asked her like
what did she probably realized she had a
dog yeah what had a dog I wonder reunite
oh wait does she accidentally drenched
with gasoline I didn't smell it I guess
oh wait was that the same dog there was
a picture right there let's see if we
can see actually that doesn't look like
that's maybe a different dog Oh unless
that was the dog as a puppy they does
that look like it do that looks like it
if it that looks like it if it is going
ahead like Nicolas Cage's life like it
looks it had a lot more hair than that
when I'm at it well so then she tried to
set fire to it oh that's like a Dell
kinda this was 2013 that she she was
reunited with the pet dog that she
almost set fire to well it kind of
sounds like a dog she's beautiful young
lady yeah I hope she's doing okay maybe
it could reach I don't even see she
would come on though being you should be
real interesting especially struggles
with addiction we have a lot of you know
I struggle with it and a lot of other
people do but yeah I think it could be
interesting for her to just share like
probably what it's been like cuz that's
the scary thing about Hollywood you only
know from like articles you only know
when like people were like you know the
Britney Spears situation where she's got
an umbrella and shaved your head you
don't know like what what led up to it
was the thing yeah yeah you never know
the truth really yeah they're crazy and
I think it would be interesting to talk
to her I mean just to find out like you
know where things started go off the
rails and how she got it back on track
you know yet is she blaming or not
blamed but yeah like I bet it was tough
to forgive whatever that things were
that were really bugging her you know um
that's why I did not become a child star
yeah you know you would have been a good
one I think I don't know I got you know
you look like you look like people watch
her like she looks like the kid from bed
I get that there was a video question
someone asked and I had to look at your
IMDB but they were like in Bad Santa did
you actually cut your thumb when you
think we're always like there are like
the kid from the Sandlot or the Bad
Santa kid oh I think it's charming
people say that I look like if I were a
blue but not they say I look like who's
that woman who was in Sleepless in
Seattle
Oh Rosie O'Donnell meg Ryan meg Ryan meg
Ryan yeah I'll get a meg Ryan if I see
look at that I can see it a little but
when I was 10
no you have a cuter nose in that guy and
it's just the hair I think and the eyes
maybe a little and we're just adorable I
mean both y'all would be I mean yeah you
guys I tried out for uh when I was like
ten
they had an open casting call and I'm
from North Carolina it was in Charlotte
you were not show wild crazy kids it was
like a bunch of kids doing like was the
ones with the pyramid they were looking
for the pyramid trying to win a contest
it was like it was like a it's like a
field I almost like kids competing and
different like activities that yeah like
and you went out for that yeah I went
out for the open casting call at the
mall and uh you know I have like jelly
stains on my shirt from McDonald's
breakfast oh yeah
Isis sneak a couple of those packets and
I would slick my [ __ ] hair bow at
times yeah cuz I thought chicks with
daikon jelly sideburn bury that [ __ ] up
and that stuff I held your ears so many
preservatives like yeah so the guy like
you know they have a producer like
asking all the kids question oh yeah
so fat and just like oh that's a slob
Slaven Lee as well yeah back then cuz
you know you're just like a little
awkward fat kid you don't really know
any better and he just like looked at me
in your head no that's my first
Hollywood rejection and uh was there
anything else he tried out for it
uh oh god what was so funny you know
it's funny I I watched you on a road
yeah drop a real world ever I did I sort
of did I was in college and I think
we're around the same age and uh alright
they had another open casting thing in
Raleigh where I was going to school and
I was working on a radio station and
they gave us like passes to go to the
front of the line oh yeah I could
imagine that and uh so people have been
waiting like you know all night to meet
everybody they're bonded and there and I
come in I like you know my Starbucks
like hate my goods
oh yeah the line hey hey and the line
for those things is always like the most
obtuse people it's like people really
trying it's a lot of this there's always
a lot of like I don't know maybe
desperation I feel like I don't know
over-the-top it's like big person now
yes I gotta make them see me right and
at the front of the line yeah a lot of
times that's what's there yeah very
aggressive yeah and where you're like
whoa and uh I just you know they pull us
all in in groups yeah oh yeah I remember
this yeah yeah I'll tell you know I'll
tell you I've never really talked about
it I'll talk about it know that but you
know I want to hear more about your
experience you go in and set a bar where
is it it's like yeah like a big bar and
and we they put us in groups in a big
table and you know of course they're
asking questions like where's the
craziest place you've had sex I'm like I
want to say like nineteen twenty and I'm
just like
you know I don't know I'm gay at that
point I was it and so they were asking
all these questions everyone's like you
know well I [ __ ] once on a washing
machine and everyone's like trying to
outdo each other I'm just like in my
head like it was that [ __ ] on the back
of it senior citizen yeah that's a lot
and I'm just like well I can't wait for
this group part to be over so I get my
one-on-one interview and I didn't say
one word
I didn't answer one question cuz it's
all so crazy yes people desperately like
yeah I'm dead yeah boy you're not dead
doing what goes and I had no good
stories because I was nerdy ass 20 year
old who hadn't really lived life right
and uh and they go alright thank you to
all of us
and I'm like what so I type in the
audition but I didn't answer one
question what hard to play though this
silent card nothing to say did you still
leave there thinking hey they might
reach out to me yeah well they got my
contact information I have my email
address at that point hit up my hotmail
don't say dress big sweetie oh really
but that was like I laughed so hard
later like knowing what I know now I'm
like what a dumbass yeah but I mean it
all worked out you know not to be for me
yeah wasn't to be for you isn't it I
know how like it's like sometimes you'll
want something you'll think oh this is
what I want and then later you realize
oh I'm so grateful that didn't work out
yeah it didn't happen that way because
this there was this other plan going on
for I'm supposed to fit really well
why would have been hard it wasn't hard
for someone like me who you know didn't
notice until he'd know so much about
myself yet yeah I moved to LA and still
didn't know I was gay like I was just a
little bit of a late bloomer in that way
cuz I grew up you know in the South and
North Carolina where I just didn't know
I didn't have those examples so that I
would have been like
everybody else in like this girl's dumb
[ __ ] right we all know you know so it
wouldn't have been probably been oh yeah
you might have been forced thought to
have to like really figure it out before
you were ready to figure yeah or I'd
have been that person that's like he's
cute yeah yeah you're banging dudes but
you're the one you're behind the dude
it's like you're moving too much so I
wanna hear how it happened for you how
you yeah yeah I'll tell you before just
you made me think so if you so I never
asked a gay person cuz you get you
you're 100% gay so I appreciate you
assuming I could have some bisexual I'm
flattered [ __ ] whack-ass dudes
running around 200 hours to see you bang
out Tony she might kill Tony you know
what's crazy is one day someone's gonna
walk up and actually it's gonna be the
greatest saddest most amazing [ __ ]
documentary ever did so if do you know
like cuz like I just wonder sometimes
like if you look when you're thinking
back in your life now so now you're
comfortable being yeah you know there's
no questions inside of you or anything
like that like do you can you look back
to like a seed where it's like you kind
of can wear it makes more sense yeah
yeah I mean what you know what's that
light cloud is kind of lifted you look
back to your whole life and you're like
oh my god they're they're like so money
so many things but and and now with
everything being slate so gay like
people talk about gays of all Tom yeah
YouTube you know everyone out
everybody's yeah people aren't even gay
or yeah and like being gay to some
people like
cool and you're just like like that like
you don't even know if they're genuinely
gay there's right what gays fun I want
to be on RuPaul say I want to open a
bakery someone come out of the closet
yeah there's nothing to do I'm gonna
have a fashion line so I have to be gay
yeah so it's just I think too part of it
is that people aren't like conforming to
labels and now everyone's right what
doing their thing and you know yeah I
can look back and just be like oh my god
like this is so obvious from like early
on you know you just don't know it
because any you know anyone you kind of
any dude I assume might be gay like in
my hometown would be like hey girl this
is my wife Pam and then she try to hold
his hand
oh no reprimanding her yeah so I I just
didn't know you know I was like I didn't
see any out gay person
I'm from especially women probably yeah
I mean both men and women I mean you
know any that was it a secret do that
worked at the bank that was gay you know
yeah and there was like any woman who
might I thought might be gay was like a
librarian yeah who like love mowing
grass yeah man she's doing a lot of yard
work and uh profusely gasoline spilt
soma legs you know it's a different Tom
and so you didn't you knew what gay was
but do you think it could apply to you
and anyone interesting cuz I yeah I just
sometimes wonder like what does that
feel like what is the like tasak yeah
like how does it start to like feel
inside of you where you it gets it for
me it got some point where you just
couldn't deny it anymore
Wow so there's just so much evidence
yeah and it was like I had moved out to
LA and moving out I was a big thing for
me because then I'll seen gay people
everywhere no one even batted an eye yes
like oh it's like oh thanks for me I
felt like so stupid I was like lose
like what am I like born in a barn it
really felt like I was an idiot or like
whoa
and then like you start to like the l
word came out you start seeing like
you're like two chicks hot chicks
kissing and you're like wow I I'm
feeling things okay and then it just
sort of bubbles up to the point where
yours like yeah yeah yes I mean you came
out of the closet one of my shows one
time oh yeah he was the last word to God
he was laughing so hard does it so if
your does it feel like do you feel like
if you feel like you get like an
erection in your vagina you're a gay no
I mean when I was watching the l word
early on yeah you're kind of just like
you you're more tingles I think than
anything yeah we don't get the the
boners to tell us like that we're
excited right more like the butterflies
and the tingles really so when that
starts having could you think back to
other times you're like oh my god I got
that feeling some but I had no idea what
was going on like yeah well I was very
intense about certain friends growing up
you know like if I were I joked at one
of my very first jokes was like I talked
about how I would get so upset from my
friend Michelle would go out on a date
with a guy and my mom would be like I
don't understand how much she's my best
friend
it's like so intense you know Euler's in
the distance looking going on her email
I mean
you just get so like angsty you know all
this stuff inside and you don't know
what it is and it used to baffle the
[ __ ] out of my mom she's like I don't
like who cares like she's on a date like
Jabba like we were should go to Chili's
together and it's more of that [ __ ] just
that like oh that like teenage like that
like goes on for long yeah and yeah
you're just the direction you're like
yeah must seem so bizarre so why because
I would have like sort of these like
intense friendships where I almost felt
like you were dating at times like
writing each other notes oh yeah on your
car something you would do with like a
boyfriend yeah I was doing that with
certain friends and so you get just so
emotionally invested in that person that
when their straightness continues and a
guy comes into the picture you're doing
yeah yeah you're like our r2d2 any
[ __ ] this you've created a non
reality right burst that bubble and it
must be a little hard even though yeah
it must have been oddly heartbreaking
almost in some ways even though you
didn't know maybe exactly what was going
on man I would just feel so
heartbreaking I feel like I mean I think
you know when I talk to other gay people
who had those experiences I think where
the heartbreak comes in is that you're
getting told no like even if it's not a
verbal no from early on because there's
like something between a closeted gay
person like if you and I had met in high
school like we'd be buddies right away
we'd be high-fiving I never had sexual
chemistry with a dude it was always like
we're homies right and uh and so even if
I do find men attractive so even if I
would find a guy attractive he would
never be reciprocated because I'm
putting my body
Who I am is putting out something I
can't control
oh interesting yeah totally
so you're just getting rejected from the
the beginning right and so that
definitely affects I think a lot of gay
people and some people oh yeah what that
worked their way through that where
they're like they build up their
self-esteem in other ways right some
people will start drinking a lot when
they get to like college and stuff to
sort of mask that pain of rejection
everybody deals with it in different
ways but yeah it's like anime I never
really thought about that there must be
this into rejection from like the way
that society is kind of built and yes
just young people too because young
people don't even know what they're
doing yeah and you know it yo it's just
like like I went to prom and stuff but
usually I ask the dude yeah what's up
mark in the back so hard so I just know
that that typical normal dating I never
had a boyfriend yeah I went on a couple
dates but oh yeah you just kind of like
dating dating sort of became like a non
thing right I became sort of the
overachiever like oh I'm gonna be in all
the clubs and I'm gonna be president of
the student government and I'm gonna
make a Z right i'ma find other ways to
just to express myself yeah that and to
get validated oh yeah I had to I had to
find validation elsewhere cuz I wasn't
the girl getting flowers on Valentine's
Day yeah I'd be like Sheila so yeah yeah
I was like getting flowers from my
brother
it's Wow cuz you really are like a you
you you also have this whole vibe of
like a real beautiful woman I feel like
oh thank you know like you really I
don't know I I don't know why I said
that even but I just yeah I don't know
just felt that but I think I think where
I was able to sort of find connections
with people
all it was more of just like being
friends with people and been genuinely
interested in them yeah and having good
conversations and I had a lot of friends
you know and and then I was sort of
became a the class clown that sort of
made people laugh and stuffs Wow I did
find laughter early on was sort of that
bridge that gap that disconnect with
people saying yeah I can do I can
totally relate to that yeah so then all
of a sudden people people are looking at
you with different a different set of
eyes you know they're not looking at you
as like oh there's that you know chubby
girl that's awkward they're like oh
she's funny she's funny she's cool
there's some yeah yeah you create
something about you and almost kind of
what an eat so much of our like who we
are and our validation becomes based on
that like response we get from the
opposite sex right yeah or you know when
we're growing up so it's almost kind of
neat that if you were able to like kind
of take that out of your picture even
though it probably affected you some I'm
sure take that out of your picture and
find other way and just be able to build
friendships with people and not have
that element be part of it yeah it's
almost kind of a weird blessing it seems
like yeah because I mean I did see early
on like people get really wrapped up
with men relationship yeah like what
readiness [ __ ] like you my mom you know
after my folks got divorced she was so
hurt by that am I am i and that
rejection from my dad that she spent
that next like ten years
oh just all that mattered was finding
that man who loved her and I would see
her just get crushed you know like cuz
she put everything into that dude to the
point where she was neglecting stuff oh
yeah the rest of my life or find another
jewel way yeah and so every all of her
validation was completely there and then
when that thing didn't work out she just
was on the floor and I and that
definitely had an effect on me where I
was man
yeah I can't do that I can't be like
that so there was like a happy medium
you know yeah so yeah in a weird way it
it allowed me to say focused I guess and
and put more value in friendships and
create a new way to to breach just to a
new worry it's almost like you didn't
get stuck into this same path because so
many of so many people it's like you get
into there and everything's based on it
[ __ ] you know Larry look for every us
life does Larry look at me but too after
science you know people make career
decisions that have changed the course
of their life for a person yeah for love
that didn't work out sometimes it did
and so you just wanted to find like you
wanted to make those decisions when it
was the right person in the right time
right so I was glad at least didn't
spend my high school college early 20s
where that was dictating all my
decisions and thoughts oh yeah a
dictated all my nightmare day driving
across town just to masturbate I
remember biking across town to find some
titty magazines to bike five miles to
masturbate did on the weekend it was
like the biggest thing I look forward to
well back then you could you know
important wasn't as accessible oh no you
know matters like these lazy people yeah
no one's getting their step soon the
healthiest arms are strong my legs I'm
so strong from biking and masturbating
but now you date a lot of hot well
you're basically like the David Spade of
a lesbian community I feel like you get
a lot of hot chicks I've dated some very
very attractive women now I'm engaged
now you're engaged now I'm spoken for
but we have a question that came in
about that actual list yeah have you set
a date for your wedding yet you set a
date for your wedding yet yeah her
mother
they only be allowing her a certain
amount of words woman you've got one
question make it short you got nine
words Rhonda oh right keep it short and
sweet uh we have not set a date for our
wedding yet we got engaged like two
years ago what's going on even the bride
and I'm like what's happening yeah uh no
I mean well she moved out here we've
been together four and a half years and
the first year was long distance and
then I wanted us at least living
together a year to see if we still like
each other good idea so once we hit the
year mark I wanted she made so many
sacrifices she moved from Chicago she
was a kindergarten teacher left it all
and uh she was working in the inner city
of Chicago and just that was her passion
and so she gave up all these things for
me
so I felt like I needed to show her
earlier because I probably would have
maybe waited like another year to get
engaged but I wanted to show her I was
serious about us and appreciated the
sacrifices she made so I proposed to her
but neither of us had an intention of
getting married right away I like to be
in any hurry
uh we are gonna get married sometime
this year I just only Twenties got a
planet yeah 2029 you about eight hours
laughs yeah it's just uh I think
normally when people getting engaged
there's like usually it's the bride
whoever the we're both brides but
technically but that Brides usually like
very much like all right I've been
dreaming about this my whole life
right here's the thousand things I want
to do well she and I never dreamt of
getting married because you know we just
again that wasn't my fantasy I think
that was never gonna happen for me
even if you think about the wedding cake
is just one woman saying up the bar so
yeah so we don't have these all these
things we've always wanted to do so for
us we're just like and we've lived
together from now for you know
over three years and it feels like we're
married we will get married but it's
just one of us has to frickin plan
something right so I think I just gotta
find like a wedding planner yeah or get
one of those planner books that books
that say plan or on them yeah there you
go you know but yeah yeah Ahmadi did go
to Pinterest yeah we just kind of want
to have a party I think we'll probably
get married at the courthouse or
something yeah like that she kind of
like she don't like to be the center of
attention
mhm she's very like she does not want to
say vows in front of people she don't
want to be walking down an aisle she is
like so it's kind of funny so I'm like
well we gotta have a party I was get
married yeah you gotta yeah you gotta
have some yeah a nice celebration it's
almost like when like people never
celebrate their birthday do some you got
to celebrate it well you just I just
want it's just there she is oh yeah
I met her before I met her yeah I think
where we ran into each other for like at
a strange place and I'm aware of what
she's awesome she's she's beautiful and
so smart and and lovely and she comes on
the road with me a lot but she's she's
kind of joined the circus that is being
a stand-up comedians partner you know oh
yeah bad huh it's a different world and
always you know Chicago is an awesome
City yes I was fine in LA if you're not
in the business you're killing what is
this place yeah so it's been an
adjustment for her but I think she's
finally starting to feel at home
so now we're in a good place with LA and
making friends and then it feels like a
good time to get married
oh if you want to plan it but oh my god
shrimp if you'd like to bike to our
wedding and masturbate and dude the
whole time I was bike and I would try to
look my main goal while biking was to
look like I wasn't gonna masturbate when
I got in the whole time that all [ __ ]
everybody knows that I'm biking across
town of jerk-off where were you going
like a new uh my basketball coach had a
bunch of
nudie mags he kept into the bathroom
under the same your so you would go to
your basketball coach's house oh yeah
and be like yo can I borrow some of
those amazing oh I wouldn't tell me dude
I'm just going there might a know how to
do a bowel movement for about two hours
I got that and then I would be so
embarrassed to come out of the door I
would go through the window of this
house and leave the [ __ ] bathroom
door locked so I would lock myself in
and it was one of those locks like the
locks you put the little latch in the
back oh my god why did he let you keep
coming over I think it had this bad GI
tract or something things are so
different back in the days but some like
wow I got with teachers too and like
they would come to my house like
nowadays is really gonna sue you yeah
you know they're like back in the day
you were just like yes my hanging out
with my teacher yeah everything's a
lawsuit now that's what that's one thing
that's messed up a lot of things in
America is just everything you know
lawyers got so happy everybody found
there's easy ways to make money it's
almost like yeah everything's a lawsuit
you know so they have to make everything
safe they have to make everything I
can't do this that you know the school
bus driver can't say things to the kids
just like there's no living anymore
yeah well everyone's like walking on
eggshells you don't know what you're
gonna say that's gonna offend somebody
people you know it's ridiculous though
what I don't understand how why it's so
it doesn't feel real though it feels
like it's real like if you look online
like if you're on like yahoo.com it
feels real the outrage and the [ __ ]
if you just read that right and you're
not alive as a human but it feels like
in the world things aren't exactly like
that as much I don't think so I mean
yeah I don't know I've never thought
nothing has ever happened to me I'm like
I'm gonna sue that person yeah like I
just think you just work things out like
you just gotta work it out yeah and you
know you hit somebody's car call your
insurance yeah you know it's not like
I'm gonna sue you I don't know it's like
oh I think we're the only country that
really is so latisha
in that way yeah I think so too there's
so much money here too yeah you know
people's all's you know chasing money
yeah okay my story about yes so I went
to when I was I was going to university
Arizona's and they had auditions there
you do these have auditions at like 6 or
7 schools around the country or real
world and Road rules University
Arizona's a good one to go to yeah kind
of a party school right no that's
Arizona State okay if you want to
basically cut the top of your car off
with a [ __ ] welding torch and also
cut your sleeves off to match your
[ __ ] car okay and buy a little bit of
turquoise yeah
then University Arizona yeah so and they
oh it was definitely it was uh it was
just hot what was it like it was fun a
lot of classic rock fans all four years
no I was actually there for one okay
semester gotcha so I went there for one
semester and they had auditions at a bar
called gentle bends I think it sounds
like a [ __ ] place that's definitely
gonna get sexual harassment so they had
and I went in there and man I was having
I was depressed bruh I mean I'm half of
my life I'm depressed but so this was a
time when I was and I went in there and
they had auditions and yeah they sat us
in a group and and they just started
talking him yeah they started talking to
people yeah and uh and I was and I just
remember being like I bet half y'all
would be afraid to [ __ ] some twins
that's what I said right cuz
[ __ ] was getting weird like one guy
yelling the first guy was like gay but
then wasn't gonna be gay
came back from the dark side he said and
then went back to like everybody had
like a crazy story one guy was doing
[ __ ] Renaissance Fairs and [ __ ] I'm
like [ __ ] dude yeah I'm down to nothing
right now you know crazy sounds like I
bet neither one of y'all would would
[ __ ] twins you know you know what to say
and so then when I'm there leaving and
there was a girl in our group
she literally stood up she's on the
highest heels you could be on she stood
up in the belt and she got [ __ ] asked
to go to the next down right so then
what happened was when I'm walking out
of there yeah the man like taps on the
shoulder and gives you this packet and
it was like a big packet yeah and it was
literally like 30 pages of stuff and he
said hey fill this out and mail it in
and you'll hear from us in likes within
six weeks yeah so for six weeks I was
excited you know it was like who knows
and then I never heard from and that was
it so then the next year mm-hmm I'm at
Louisiana State okay and they had
auditions there and every year they had
like six campus where they would have
audition so it just happened to be the
next year that they had it at this
campus okay so I'm like okay so I went
again and then and I kind of knew okay
the first run you say something wild you
know my twins line again yeah and then
and then watch somebody fall over so I
don't remember what I did the second
time but I did something always good
that's good
and I remember actually I remember so
then they had you they had you fit you
know you fill out the packet and this
time I didn't try to be wild on the
packet I just tried to be like just talk
about my life and so then they called
one time and then they made you set up a
camera and they would call you and
interview you and you had to mail them a
tape okay and then they did that three
more times and it was with therapists
and different types of people that work
at their company okay then they get to
talk to a therapist yes I still know
where this lady Laura Kerkorian that's
her name real sweet lady but yeah and
then they had you drive to a regional
like they had like 20 or 30 people drive
to a regional place and so I drove and I
went in the hotel yeah and it's and in
the hall in the hotel it smelled kind of
it was like kind of it was in a urban
area and it smelled like a lot of like
urban kind of haircare products and
stuff you know kind of like because I
grew up you know with Rhydon let's cool
with a lot of black kids a lot of black
kids at school and I was like oh it
smells kind of like black people in here
you know and I remember the saying that
right when I sat down and I could just
see their eyes just like they're like we
got a race we got a ringer and I didn't
mean it like oh man [ __ ] it smells like
black yeah you were trying to say that I
was like oh it smells like exactly what
I say that's it that smells like a black
woman in here I think maybe that's you
kind of specific you know yeah and they
did that's what it's you know and I was
right no joke two seconds later a black
woman comes in and asked everybody a
question in the room and I was like oh
is that maybe it's that lady but um yeah
and then so then I remember after that
they yeah they would ask me more
questions about race or and because I
wanted people that sort of like push
buttons and stuff right yeah they wanted
people that would say stuff that was
outrageous something right or just I
don't know if I was just too naive to
even know you know filter maybe
yeah there's no filter yeah but also I
think people knew I wasn't you know I've
never come from a place of like I'm I
have any anger or yeah maybe had more
curiosity than it right you just seem
kind of misunderstood by the rest of the
cast at least what was oh yeah aired I
think I was and then cast members at a
certain point they start to become cast
member right so they're like oh okay I'm
this personally
yeah one who's gonna you know like if
anybody says anything gets out of line
I'm gonna be that you know yeah some
ladies like oh I'm gonna come out of the
closet you know even though I don't even
know if I'm gay you know some guys like
a woman that guy was gonna [ __ ]
everybody you know some guys like I'm
gonna boss steroids you know everybody's
got different role right but yeah anyway
so that was that and then one day they
called and said hey do you want to go on
road rules do you want to go on this
trip yeah and it was crazy because at
the time so many people watch the show
right TV really yeah MTV was huge and I
remember thinking man this is gonna be
just a life change ya know I'm going to
a basketball game that day and walking
into this the stadia the basketball
place mm-hmm and thinking man next year
if I do that show next year half these
kids would know who I was
yeah when I came in here mm-hmm and uh
and that was kind of it that was a just
a wild feeling kind of and then when I
then I went into the channel went back
to LSU and it was a nightmare oh really
people were so mean he would throw [ __ ]
at me all the time make fun of me call
me all kind of names yeah I'm her one
time I was at a bar I was waiting to go
into a bar and some kid threw a bottle
and it whizzed right by my head and
shattered on the UH on this bar right
next to me oh my god nuts and I was like
man I gotta get out of here yeah this is
not safe for me to be around here right
one night some people I forgot about
this I was at a bar about Tulane
University and some kids started [ __ ]
with me and then started chasing me and
I ran up to a house I banged on the door
this late it was a girl as a group of
girls lived there yeah someone more
asleep this one girl was awake and she
let me in and then these people ran
around their house and we're throwing
things through their windows oh my just
drunk kids like 3:30
they broke like three windows in these
people's house and I was just like Jesus
dude I'm yeah it was just just a couple
of weird you know [ __ ] that was real
scary yeah you know I was like I
probably need to get out of here was it
that they thought you had like like they
wanted to take you down a couple pegs
yeah I think so and I don't know if I
had ego about it I can't remember
don't really think I did I mean I was
sick that you were on TV yeah this guy
thinks he's cool this guy's different
I don't think it was a matter of how you
were acting just like oh he's on TV [ __ ]
that guy yeah yeah it was just a lot of
like really [ __ ] that made me
uncomfortable yeah I was like I'm not
doing this yeah I'm crazy I didn't I was
scared yes that would have been I
wouldn't have either
yeah and that [ __ ] was scary the
basketball game oh yeah they're all
their own bottles that yeah yeah there
was just some scary moment everybody
right right but that was just a couple
of things it was like oh I'm not gonna
you know I'm not gonna die down here
because somebody wants to be a prick you
know right and that's when you moved to
LA I think that's gonna move to LA yeah
but anyway that's kind of a [ __ ]
downer stories I mean that sucks but it
is it's interesting yeah that was the
journey of it it kind of illuminates
we're talking like a man to buy and
choose child star and stuff once
authorial it's just never as good as
right perceive it's gonna be in your
head you were young oh yeah I was young
I was 19 yeah one cool thing was one
time they had flu middles back to Los
Angeles for something and they sent a
limousine to pick me up yeah which was
so bizarre dude I'm sleeping on my
friend's floor we shared a floor and he
would always bring him he's crazy if I
could and I would happened to hide and
[ __ ] kind of sleep by the closet you
know under a bunch of sheets oh look
nobody was in there oh my god and uh
anyway so I had to I had the limousine
stop at the bus stop because I use these
way to this one bus stop and pick up
everybody and got in and drop them all
at school and that was a [ __ ] a
pretty cool day hey we're going directly
to campus it's like 7:30 in the morning
people are freezing oh my god that's
that's like that comedy club up in
where's it saying Sunnyvale or something
they always would send a rooster yeah I
guess stretch limo for does you you're
like it's white this is a tease
yeah you guys I hear one book bag and
like a satchel of merch okay I was
embarrassed the only place this would be
okay in Vegas yeah we're in Sunnyvale
yeah Twitter
oh here's looking down on me that's
crazy
what's one of the weirdest clubs you
played over the years you feel like
there's something weird when you were
starting you know they're the one that
tripped me out was in Peoria the jukebox
lucky Ori but I never played the club
the comedy club is right beside a strip
joint there's a strip club on one side
of it and then right across the street
is a racecar track but like we're dudes
just like it's like the race car tracks
like mud mm-hmm like demolition derby
yeah kind of but they're racing where so
it's crazy loud and weird dude you know
it's kind of more of a passion thing
than like anybody can be raised there
like buddy can race these cars in their
backyard like racist people show up like
I'm ready like nah man it's not that as
cars yeah that was a trip my everyone
was so nice but like so dudes would
wander over from like the strip club
drunk me like or Emma and I'm like so it
was so fun but you like if the door
would open it was insane so you couldn't
like not talk you had to talk the whole
time
oh yeah it would drown out the agents
yeah that was probably one of the most
memorable ones the jukebox
something like that comedy jukebox or
something I need to go there that
yeah I performed once back when I did
Last Comic Standing
oh yeah I forgot you did that you do too
right yeah I made it's like the final 40
or something yeah I was saying it was
like that kind of thing they uh I
started touring pretty much right after
that but you know nobody only people who
knew who I was right a couple people
yeah watch the show but they like hired
me for a charity event in Virginia Beach
they're like oh it's gonna be like
sit-down dinner it's gonna be really
nice it's supposed to be like sort of
through a gay organization and I guess
like a week before the guy in charge
quit and some other guy was just like
handed the project and he was like uh it
was like ended up being like a biker bar
like a Harley you know the dinner was
like a Chinese buffet with like eight
options and there was no gay people in
sight and I had my mom meet me up there
from North Carolina cuz you know I was
new to touring instead yeah Anna [ __ ]
man
the stage was like a crate like a [ __ ]
you know coca-cola crate and the light
was the light was a clamp when I was
clamping and the mic was like sounding
like a karaoke like a kid's karaoke
machine I was like oh comedy and they
hired an opener who you said came over
the Comedy Store Steve Moore he was he
was an old comic and he was supposed to
do 20 and I was supposed to do 40 and uh
he lasted two minutes he because it was
bite your was like biker dudes that was
like what the [ __ ] is and uh and there
was maybe only like 20 people there he
lasted to two minutes he got hit they
still painted me he got his jacket he
left and I was like dude you can at
least be make it 21 in here come on
and I got 20 bikers looking at me like
I'm insane
and my mom's just looking at me like
what profession have you chosen and III
don't by the grace of God I just like
somehow figured out what to talk about
for 40 minutes and got it done got it
done but you know that's early on when
you're just like I don't really have 40
minutes so I think I was like asking
what's hey sir like where are you from
you know that [ __ ] like crowd working I
mean I've never been scared in my life
to be on a crate yeah so hard you think
every step is [ __ ] no you move is
like are you know you I remember we me
and a friend of mine went to a school
University of Arkansas Little Rock yeah
or some are maybe even been a smaller
one right and like we had to be on a
freight that was outside yes it was
outside we had to be on a crate yeah
people brought sofas and everything they
were kind of fired up yeah and we didn't
know what to do we had no plans yeah and
another comedian we chat about eight
minutes right yeah I fell an hour we
stopped before it like a store that had
a bunch like a dollar store got a bunch
of [ __ ] weird prizes yeah and we had
two girls take pregnancy tests at the
school there to go ahead and take them
and bring them back to the crate back
we're standing on her [ __ ] crate
outside and the audio was good though
and then both of them came back negative
man and won something if it came back
positive you get a baby wonder was wet
when guy started pacing in the distance
really holy [ __ ] like your prizes
condoms I had a crazy show it it was
also in Arkansas at college and I was
one of my first college gigs and at the
time I had this
character cuz I came from I did
growlings first and then oh
transitioning to stand up so I have like
I tested for uh Sanel twice I had this
whole past comedy thing of characters
and improv and all that stuff and I I
had a character that was a Hooters
waitress named Darlene Witherspoon and
so I filmed myself like in an alley
pretending to be a Hooters waitress and
it it I think a vial of viral viral but
it like a lot of people watched it and
so I was sort of known at that time as
like Darlene Witherspoon and so I got
hard to do this College and they
mentioned that they were fans of Darlene
Witherspoon so I just assumed well then
that's probably why they're higher than
me all the students must be famous
darling Witherspoon so I again didn't
have a ton of material you gotta build
it up and uh so I at those colleges you
have to do an hour and so I did like 40
minutes I found my way through that and
then my big idea was that I was gonna
take my clothes off and under my clothes
would be my hodor's outfit where I'd be
in this tight Hooters shirt and these
tiny orange shorts mm-hmm so I I take it
all thinking like here comes the big
finale I'm in my time this tiny outfit
I'm going through the rows of kids they
all are horrified none of them ever
heard of [ __ ] character it was the
people that hired me who were fans like
you know advisor these students were
just like the other 18 like why is this
fat girl in a hooters outfit and she's
why is she like everybody was like oh my
closer up on stage in a pile okay well I
misread that situation and you note
immediately to that it wasn't going well
no and there it is
oh damn my fat asses and this hooters
outfit fine and I just these kids were
just you know when you're 18
they're like uncomfortable for they're
like yes they're not in on the joke
consider going to those events are
[ __ ] [ __ ] they this thing they
are they feel sorry for you they're like
yeah oh man like what it you know yeah
it happened to this poor woman they're
like I'm part of the Native American
initiative here at [ __ ] Fayetteville
Arkansas it was like a good 15 minutes
left you have to commit to that [ __ ] but
you're just like I'm gonna prance around
in my owners outfit just acting like
this is normal
zoom out my worst show was I mean
there's so many of them but right one of
them for sure
University of either North Florida or
Central Florida their battle of the
bands oh man and so they hired I got to
be the host the emcee okay so I go out
in the beginning I'm thinking I'll do a
couple minutes warm them up and then and
you know it'll get the crowd going and
start to bring up a band well I go out
there and they don't give a [ __ ] about
me to some dude honestly through the
American flag at me I remember it was a
big one it was on a thing and it just
came and hit the stage and I couldn't
tell that was like a good thing so they
literally boo me off stage and it was
about 800 kids in a small venue and they
were all excited because I think it was
a Greek thing and it was their battle of
the bands so each one had a band that
was gonna play yeah so I go backstage
and I burned through all my material
yeah they couldn't even hear it they
were so pissed I go backstage I bring
out a band and like okay you just need
to do you know about four or five
minutes between each man now feels like
an hour when your spine literally crawl
out of my ass hide in my sock dude
so I just came and literally I kept
coming out to the point about the fourth
time and it became funny that I was
coming back out again yeah but man I
remember crying internally like tears
forming but not coming out of my face
and only going backwards into my throat
and it was just painful man oh my god it
was dark we got a question right here
came in all right
fortune two questions do you wear a bra
and would you or have you ever shot a
porno oh my god I got I get sort of I
didn't have the thing did she say do I
wear a bra she said yeah what did she
said yet do you wear a bra and have you
ever or would you shoot a porno do I
wear a bra
I do wear like a like it kind of like a
shout out North Carolina right here is a
hootenanny hootenanny nice
I do wear a bra I just I don't wear the
ones with the wires and the things so my
my boobs should be like here if I did do
that a little bit like midsection
they're kind of like man boobs a little
bit but they say women oftentimes
they're not wearing the appropriate size
bra really I got to go to one of those
bra specialists and get like a better
one probably and would I shoot a porno
that's a big no yeah I mean I'm sure
that comes as a shock to people watching
or listening oh no this is not a porn
body this is a turn the lights off
you know no no candles even know about
darkness
I'm or one lamp in the distance oh
speaking of no lamps here's a guy who
definitely just woke up says dick fuel
hey what's up Theo what's that fortune
my question for both of you is when
Netflix calls is it a call do you have
to go in for meeting well how does that
go down when they go hey you're getting
the special how does that work also if
you could turn into a motorcycle
would you thanks brother and he said
it's his shirts a dick fuel and the
motorcycle man I think and then dig dig
fuel in the motorcycle er motor I don't
know cycles maybe he likes motorcycles
um yeah how does it work cuz you have a
new special coming I do on Netflix
yeah January 21st it's called sweet and
salty it's my first hour it is so yeah
I've done 2 half hours I did one for
Comedy Central and then one for Netflix
so I'm excited it's so exciting super
pumped for that and uh yeah for me why
did the half-hour first as part of the
stand-ups it was like Nate forgot yeah
Nikki Glaser and that happened they call
your agents I don't know what how it
went with you but for that they called
my agents and then just sort of offer it
and so that helped me sort of get in the
door with Netflix and then they I think
we went to them like a year and a half
later to do an hour and they're like no
because it's gotten very competitive
very competitors saying no to a lot more
people nowadays cuz there's so well they
make so many special make so many
specials they said no why they just in
fells like that it was time you know
it's all about timing and stuff so yeah
I mean it's just it's and it's their
opinion yeah and and and so I just sort
of and and I got the same sort of answer
from other people which I was kind of
surprised by was like I think I'm ready
but I just was like alright it sort of
forced me to kind of put my head down
and just hit the road even harder so I
spent a year and a half just I mean I've
been torn since two
ten pretty much since last comic so I
hadn't stopped that process but I just
like cranked it up even more where I was
just like gone like every weekend just
like beat beating this set as hard as I
could
trying to make it better trying to get
it to a place where it they couldn't
deny it or who be it Netflix or whoever
yeah and uh so but you don't really
think about that as the end goal you're
just like this is what I'm doing I'm a
comic do you hope for that yeah I
thought of like what's gonna happen yeah
bigger picture you can't control you
can't control someone's gonna buy it or
not and I and so I got it to a really
great place and uh and then they sort of
came at the same time I'm doing a
morning radio show for them now on
Sirius XM
mm-hmm just uh it's me and Tom papa oh
my god called water joke and so it sort
of came like you're gonna do this radio
show with them and also we want your
special oh wow so it was I think a phone
call and then you meet with them later
but you know I just I I don't know for
me it was like I I've gotten plenty of
those in my career but I'm very
motivated by those knows it makes me
like you know I got I was on a pilot the
Tina Fey produced I was so excited about
and it didn't go and it just like
something was like alright you got a no
but you have Tina Fey's e're for like
five more minutes what are you gonna do
with that so I pitched her show you know
saw my own show and we've shot that
pilot they didn't go but that led to me
being on the Mindy project so I just try
to use those nose as a big motivator
yeah and now I shot my special I said I
shot it in Charlotte sweet North
Carolina was it called sweet and salty
sweet and salty yeah and I love sweet
and salty right you know and uh you shot
at North Carolina Charlotte in North
Carolina
Wow came out yeah right
I meant a lot to me because I've been in
LA 17 years and they don't really get to
see my world and yeah what I do much and
so to get to share that with them was a
special for me and it's a very
autobiographical set where I go through
like birth elementary school I take
everybody on this sort of timeline
journey mm-hmm and then I'm bring it
back sort of full circle and I talk a
lot about being from the south you know
and because I think the South gets a bad
rap in a lot of ways a bad there's
[ __ ] everywhere or ignorant people
but I [ __ ] love a southern people
have been so good to me and I'm proud to
be from the south and I wanted to have
it filmed in the south because I think
people associate the south with certain
people I might want I'm from the south
yeah I feel like I'm a good person
yeah the South has so many good people
yeah I wonder sometimes why they why
it's almost like the people that make a
lot of the news stories have never even
they're not from there yeah they have no
idea most of the people I know are good
people
yeah have manners they're kind they
loving do something our neighbors would
help anybody would help a neighborhood
no matter the color of their skin
there's no % it's just a man it just
makes me so mad sometimes yeah so I just
wanted to like I'm not ashamed of that
part of myself and my past at all I'm
when I'm southern but I'm also gay and
I'm also a daughter I'm also a sister
yeah so I tell a lot of stories that I
think a lot of men in particular kind of
assumed they wouldn't be able to relate
to my story mm-hmm and a lot of dudes
come to my shows like with their
girlfriend or their wife's and you can
kind of see them be like alright what do
you got and then by the end they're the
ones they're like oh my god I like that
was I had such a good time yeah and that
means so much to me cuz I'm like I'm
trying to just make people feel good I'm
telling stories that everybody can
relate to yeah so I'm really proud of
the special I just want you to watch it
cuz I don't know just I feel like I'm
I'm presenting a different look outlook
on that world yeah when they also
haven't uh I was talking about this
yesterday I think we had Tommy Tommy via
Tommy Larry yesterday the newscast she's
like oh she's and she's very
conservative you know but um I was
talking about they haven't had anyone
from the south and comedy since the Blue
Collar Comedy Tour right really yeah
there was a big Reba I mean they've had
they had word that Reba show which was
great yeah Reba shows great yeah never
watch that yeah I love the shows great
yeah there was a big gap you'd get and
so it's like you tell me in a place
where there's so much history so much
good storytelling so much creativity
right and that's a thing like
southerners are such storytellers okay
and that's a lot of my stand-up is I'm
just telling stories you know not I'm
not doing the light setup punchline
setup punchline that's never gonna be my
style I'm like here's a funny story and
it's gonna make me laugh you know on the
way to telling you what happened and I
think that's a big southern thing I
think like you know we tell stories
because we grew up with like people that
you would think like that that's not a
real person yeah but no I grew up with
that and that was like my entire
childhood and I grew up watching
everybody tell these crazy stories and
they're like full of life and full and I
mean of course you know that influence
me influence you and a lot of southern
comics you know but yeah I just I feel I
felt like being gay you're sort of just
like thought okay well you're a gay
comic right I go no I'm I'm still
southern yeah that's still a huge part
of my upbringing I still have my accent
like it's I go I want a house in North
Carolina yeah it's a big part of me
that's amazing no I love hearing you say
that yeah you know southern women to
like what you're telling me there's not
I can't imagine how many great
personalities have been missed out on
yeah better southern women you know that
are just and I think
us other women also don't think of
getting into comedy right probably
because I think in some of the in some
of those spaces they're still like more
of a you know men kind of do comedy
right a lot of times yeah I mean like
when I started a store like Sarah Sarah
Tiana was there so that was nice to see
like she's from George oh yeah she's
great like another stand of it you know
there's like a handful of his neighbor
guys she's done so well yeah and there's
a girl on Instagram - Chelsea Lynn do
you follow her uh-huh yeah trailer trash
- yeah yeah they can ever look brown
cells oh did you yeah their video of her
Brian's mom I was there that day you
were I was there that day yeah they had
a big charity of it there how can we
watch it I don't know if we can watch it
on here right now oh my god it was so
fun his mom's a blue Browns mom she's
out there she was driving around with a
golf cart smoke away yeah okay Luke
Bryan and his wife Caroline asked me to
help rank Luke's mom this is Chelsea
so
[Music]
stop
this town of moms moms having a
cigarette they're staying about golf
course
[Applause]
so Lou's wife Caroline is a big pranker
oh really
so every year she does 12 days of
pranksmen so this is like they said
she's this was months before Christmas
she set this up because they had a big
charity event at their house and a golf
tournament it was it was like a bunch of
stuff it was like a gun-range it was
putting fish in it was like a day
outside and they played like music and
stuff and raise money for the Brett
Boyer Foundation which helps kids with
like heart defects oh wow Down syndrome
stuff like that that's beautiful yeah
that sounds like fun
oh it was awesome cuz that you talk
about getting back to my roots like I
don't get to do something like that very
often you live in LA I'm on tour all the
time yeah like just to go to some nice
farm and like fish
you know shooting targets and stuff and
uh that's skeet shooting oh really
yeah it was awesome and then I had like
the all the like Jason Aldean all these
guys were playing music with him that
night and uh I think you rock came out
he did yeah with Nashville it was yet in
Nashville at there they have like a
house and it's like a form its in
leapers fork out there no I honestly
don't know they like shuttle you
somewhere just you know they don't
people know where they live yeah that's
all what's so funny is like my my
fiance's like you know living in Chicago
twelve years and this from Michigan and
they go do you guys want to shoot a
rifle right yeah we'll try it and so
they're like five targets and I I try
shoot I hit like the target maybe once
she gets the rifle she's like she nailed
all five targets without even like
flinching I'm just like kindergarten
surprised okay very security right yeah
protect me I'm the alarm went off one
time and she and I was like we gotta
wait for the cops she's like no I'm
going in and I stood in the doorway I
was like I have the hand on the panic
button of the alarm system should
anything happen to you I'm of no use
don't let this big body for you oh yeah
I'm like that's what I'm weak um very
straight get your manboobs
[Laughter]
and it's hilarious yeah I'm so excited
for your special yeah that's how it
worked
yeah yeah did you call they call you
yeah I had one yeah let me see 2015 I
think and they came out and saw me and
then they said yep we'll do a special
they gave us like a certain budget yeah
and that was it shot mine in New Orleans
you know we're sure I really wish I
hadn't just because yeah oh I am glad my
mom got to be there got to be there my
family a lot of family and friends got
to come so that was the best part was
just them getting to be part of the
experience yeah
the tough part was just people there had
not there hadn't been a lot of comedy
they're the same same with me so a lot
of people didn't know what to do they
didn't know when you were joking
sometimes they didn't know one person
was yelling defense for half the thing
they thought I was like a sporting thing
oh my god ladies yelling defense had to
throw her out oh my god he's out of her
[ __ ] mind dude
yeah I had a similar thing where the
show started like an hour late cuz you
know you're filming they're setting up
the stage and everything so people are
like piss about that and you're just
kind of wolf at tapings it's different
than a regular show at tapings they do
kind of start late because they're
trying to get all the stuff to fake
cameras and lights and so everybody got
hammered in the like Oh an hour just
people pounding it so people but people
were so excited for me and I appreciate
that out I love that they were like you
know they were yelling at me my whole
set oh wow some some gay guys are even
yelling less me like as a term of
endearment but I might do
I don't want lesbian being yelled out
during my entire Netflix yeah they're
gonna like some editors gonna have to be
like uh-oh through this whole thing yeah
it's funny people don't realize the key
don't just cheer the whole time yeah
like just listen to the show right some
people like and we're gonna cheer more
[ __ ] let them know it's like they're
gonna know yeah I wouldn't I will woman
whoo
when I would say the punch line or
whatever she got that's right and I
might not or like yep that happened
me this was my first show I had to be
like ma'am I love you but can light you
not do that and she kept doing it like
yep
that violent shut the [ __ ] up it was
bonkers and then the second show started
late too they had been drinking all
night
so it was rowdy it was rowdy yeah yeah
so I I'm glad I the same I'm glad I did
it there because I got to share that
with friends and family but yeah you
know it's risky it is yeah because
people think it's just a party we're
coming out to party which a live show is
yeah any live show you're just like yeah
I want you to have the most fun ever
let's fund you and have the best hour
and a half ever yell what you want we'll
do it
yeah but a taping you're like yeah yeah
it's tough to be up there and be a
comedian and also trying to feel like
you have to kind of like produce you
know like you know yeah
via the you know a controller as well
that part was the most interesting
because you it's harder to like stay in
the moment you know why cause a lot of
show it's just like so natural and
they're just like I'm connecting with
you you're connecting with me but like
when you're taping the producer part of
you is like oh I messed that line up
you're kind of like or you're like
thinking about where you're standing
there's oh it's something a little more
unnatural about it but then by the
second show that night it was like okay
let's just let's just do this yeah yeah
guess it gets to be uh yeah let's just
do this yeah the second time yet you're
like yeah you you just start to realize
okay there's things I can control things
I can let me just best well you know
like I said I just want people to watch
it January 21st January 21st on this
sweet and salty I love it that's so
exciting where are you gonna watch it
I'll be in New York doing press so I
guess somewhere in New York and then I
leave like two days later to film a
movie oh really
yeah I'm gonna Puerto Rico oh wow
I never filmed there before but it
should be fun San Juan do you know Oh
same one yeah it's a crime-fighting San
Juan to shoot for two days on that movie
then find a Pittsburgh to shoot a day on
another movie flying out on the red-eye
that night to go back to San Juan and I
stood in the land I go back to filming
and it's crazy but it's good I mean I've
always been trying to balance the stand
up acting life I'm just happy that
anybody wants to hire me so yeah if
that's what it takes I'll do it
yeah you've always done what it takes it
sounds like yeah I mean I come from you
know I come from very nice working folks
my mom was a special ed teacher for 30
years
Wow my dad was uh worked at a trucking
company and then the last ten years he's
basically been a janitor at an
elementary school
oh wow tart like in charge he's a
janitor but also he's in charge of the
janitors there so I'm very like
working-class like we didn't have much
growing up and you just learned from an
early age you gotta work yeah nothing's
handed to you and uh you know I started
working at recreation apartment I was
like 15 did you really mm-hmm
live in softball fields and picking up
trash and I were correct the protocol
Belmont Recreation Department er D they
called it uh-huh and uh and I loved it
and you know but we just I got when I
moved to LA I had $25 in my pocket yeah
you know figure it out you know yeah
you're just like I have a goal I want to
keep a roof over my head and for me it
was never about trying to be famous or
anything I didn't think someone like me
could be on TV I was like I just want to
pay my bills and uh and you know there
were times where before I got like
Chelsea Lately I like had no I was done
with money and nothing and I but I was
in it like scared me because I thought
why can't like call my parents
they can't bail bail me out of a rent or
something but there was something in me
that knew like even if
you have nothing I'll go work in a
Starbucks yeah I'll go yes I don't give
a [ __ ] I'll do whatever it takes to pay
the bills and I'll figure it out yeah
yeah there is something nice when you
have a family member you grow up having
like just an understanding of how to
figure things out
you know I feel like that's one thing I
learned as I get older I see sometimes
there's people that depend on other
people to figure things out for them and
there's people they're able to figure
things out for themselves you know and
there's there's really a it's beautiful
it's a beautiful thing if you've had to
figure things out for yourself yeah
because it's such us I mean that's the
it's just such a skill you know it's
such a skill that some people even
realize they don't have they're right oh
I need the government to do this or I
need you know like it's like yeah to
have that skill to be able to survive
you gotta be able to pull yourself up by
your own bootstraps you know like I find
the people that I know who've been
handed things their whole life they
don't know how functions yeah come on
dude no yeah and it's just like uh as
hard as it was growing up was like you
know we had I'm not saying I had it
worst anyway else no you know but yeah
there were times the lights were cut out
those nervous you know the pot the water
bill hadn't been paid and you just her
like all right yeah we you know we had a
young age of pool our money together and
be like all right let's pay the water
you know you just figure it out and so
I'm um my mom is a teacher like in the
summers she had to go get a job
waitressing at like a sizzler time I
used to like sizzler yeah it was called
Quincy's Oh was it really yeah good it
was there's no ego in it like he was
embarrassing for her she had to wait on
like friends family families and stuff
but that there's no ego when it comes to
taking care of yourself and your family
yeah just got to do what you got to do
so I think it helped prepare me for LA
for this business because you know it's
like I'm lucky that I'm working but I
don't know what's gonna happen
yeah you can't yeah you have to there's
no city that'll make you survive I don't
feel like like here yeah and I was here
you know eight years for me to DOM
at this so I did do other jobs you know
you just figure out other ways to make
money yeah yeah so I'm just always like
hustling as a result I never stop
yeah well and that's a nice thing
something that never stops you know I
think that thing never stops like the
desire to achieve or to figure it out
well the flip side of it is that you're
so consumed with this being secure and
making sure you're never in that
position again is that you almost work
too much much yeah
where I spread myself pretty thin but
I'm doing what I love so at least I got
that part you know I don't think my dad
loved being a janitor yeah but you gotta
do what you gotta do so at least I love
my job and I get to do really cool
things
yeah its drawl of sweeping now I [ __ ]
love ya my mommy's no it's sweet man I'd
seen everything I'd sweep stuff that
wasn't ours cars I sweep the damn
sidewalks I go sweeping halfway down the
dam blah yeah come games like that's not
always come back oh yeah my dad's a big
thing was doing floors oh he was good
with that bumper yeah he's stripped
floors and wax on is big thing nice to
ride on it but madness
they had this one man Jerry it was a
Janet even let me ride on that [ __ ]
buffer for a half a minute if you mean a
machine you are walking in the hall I
just told the story yesterday and one of
them said to the other one he goes hey
did you set the chairs up in the gym mr.
Ford's gonna be speaking in there this
afternoon and the guy goes president
forward he goes [ __ ] no mister for the
the zionists
that's right get those good chairs out
just so baffling to me and also beautify
all this
since working in this school everyday
I'm thinking hey man the president might
show it could have fortune beamster
thank you so much of course the other
being here and always lovely talking to
you
it's such a good time this one my
favorite uh chats we've had in here
January 21st on Netflix and um yes sweet
and salty and we're all shared on social
media I'm excited for you thank you yeah
yeah you bet thanks for coming in yeah
[Music]
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]